This concludes the first part of this lesson in which
we discussed the basic object-oriented concepts. And, we started to
look at how to perform object-oriented analysis. In the second
part of the lesson, I will introduce UML, and we will
perform the object-oriented analysis steps that we just saw using
an example. A course management system so before getting to
the second part, let me introduce the example. As we
mentioned before, the first step is to start from a textual
description of the system the we need to analyze and
that we need to build. So that's exactly what I'm going
to do. I'm just going to read through this description then we'll
reuse throughout the rest of the lesson. The registration manager sets
up the curriculum for a semester using a scheduling algorithm and
the registration manager here is the registrar. So we will refer
to the registration manager both as registration manager and as registrar
in the rest of the lesson. One course may have multiple
course offerings, which is pretty standard. Each
course offering has a number, location, and a
time associated with it. Students select four primary
courses and two alternative courses by submitting a
registration form. Students might use the course management
system to add or drop courses for a
period of time after registration. Professors use the
system to receive their course offering rosters. Finally,
users of the registration system are assigned passwords which are used for
login validation. So, as you can see, this is a kind of a
high-level description of a standard course management system. So, if you ever
used a course management system, you'll
recognize some of the functionality described here.